l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 619 de monsieur jean claude
carle à monsieur mise de l'intérieur
vous avez la parole ce président merci
main présidente madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre la question
s'inscrit tout à fait en complément de
celle de eric doligé je souhaite appeler
votre attention sur la modification de
la carte des cantons tout d'abord
l'augmentation de la superficie des
cantons si elle peut se justifier dans
certains secteurs n'est pas sans générer
des difficultés dans d'autres notamment
en zone de montagne ainsi dans mon
département haute savoie
que penser du nouveau canton
d'evian-les-bains keira de publier à
morzine de saint gingolph oger en
associant deux vallées très distinctes
aux rives du léman ou alors du nouveau
canton de saint julien en genevois
allende d'archamps à seyssel d'autre
part avec ce redécoupage des chefs lieux
de canton perdront leur statut au profit
d'un nouvel commune devenant bureau
centralisateur du nouveau canton outre
l'aspect très techno 4 et technocratique
de ce terme ceci engendre trois
conséquences importantes la première est
liée à l'histoire cette évolution avec
souvent un changement de nom et de
communes centre jette un trouble parmi
la population dans nos régions de
montagne contrainte est compartimentée
par le relief plus qu'ailleurs s'est
développé au fil du temps un sentiment
réel d'appartenance des habitants un
territoire bien défini et identifiés ce
sentiment se voit aujourd'hui quelque
peu remis en cause dans mon département
par exemple nouveau canton dossier
associant les actuels canton de douvaine
et bouaicha trois communes issues de
celui de thonon-les-bains ouest aura
pour bureau centralisateur la commune de
6 c'est aussi le cas d' pour le nouveau
canton de faverges recoupant les accus
les cantons de faverges tourne plus des
communes issues des cantons de
bonneville et d'un style vieux don ne
perd ainsi sa fonction de chef lui quand
deux cantons ne serait-il pas opportun
de trouver des dénominations plus
consensuel pour ces nouveaux cantons
dans le premier cas l'on pourrait
retenir canton du bas chablais dans le
second quand on tournait a ravi comme
l'a d'ailleurs proposé le conseil
général ces appellations correspondent à
des réalités géographiques historiques
humaine et même culturelle ce qui est
vrai en haute savoie doit bien sûr net
dans d'autres départements le second
impact de cette réforme est d'ordre
fille ancien certaines communes vont
perdre la majoration de la dotation de
solidarité rurale ce sera ainsi le cas
dans l'ancien canton de bruèges que j'ai
évoqué cette commune subira une perte de
33000 euros bogève et habère poche le
perdant respectivement 46 milles et
60000 euros dans le nouveau canton de
siedoubs veine sera privé de 120000
euros et mon chat blade cent dix neuf
mille euros aussi ne serait-elle pas
judicieux monsieur le ministre soit
d'abaisser le seuil de la dsr de 15 à 10
% de la population et ce enveloppe
constante ce qui permettrait d'annuler
ou réduire l'effet induit par la réforme
soit alors d'instaurer une sortie
progressive afin d'amortir l'incidence
la troisième conséquence porte sur
l'avenir des chefs des services publics
souvent organisés au niveau du chef lieu
de canton hors la loi va mécaniquement
supprimer au moins un sur deux nos
concitoyens s'inquiètent donc de voir
disparaître ces services publics il
convient de les rassurer à ce sujet que
le mini jeu c'est l'attachement qu'elle
vote et celui du ministre de l'intérieur
aux territoires ruraux il l'a récemment
affirmé lors d'une visite en haute
savoie et mes propositions permettraient
de leur éviter de nouvelles difficultés
alors qu'elles subissent déjà de
nombreuses aujourd'hui ne serait-ce que
celles liées à la mise en place des
rythmes scolaires je vous remercie donc
de bien vouloir m'indiquer les mesures
que vous entendez prendre afin que cette
réforme ne soit pas source de querelles
qui ne sont pas sans importance car lié
à notre histoire et qu'elle n'est pas
des conséquences aussi financière grave
pour ces communes qui subiraient ainsi
la double peine merci merci monsieur le
président car la parole et a mis ses
ministres
madame la présidente des dames et
messieurs les sénateurs ont sur le
président incarne
concernant la prise en compte du relief
dans le remodelage la carte cantonale le
ministre de l'intérieur tiens à vous
rassurer comme il s'y était engagé
durant les débats parlementaires sur la
loi du 7 mai le relief est pleinement
pris en compte dans ces travaux ainsi
parmi des 15 haussier de révision de la
carte cantonale concernant un
département de montagne déjà transmis
aux conseils généraux 12 bénéficie d'une
ou plusieurs exceptions
à la règle de la moyenne démographique
au titre du relief de la topographie de
l'enclavement et de la superficie c'est
à dire les critères définis par le
conseil constitutionnel dans sa décision
du 16 mai 2013 le ministre l'intérieur
entend également vos interrogations
concernant les actuelles du chef lieu de
canton une précision d'abord des décrets
de révision des cartes cantonales
définissent des bureaux centralisateurs
et non des chefs lieux de canton
puisqu'il s'agit de la seule obligation
en matière électorale
la territorialisation de certains
services publics sur les chefs lieux de
canton a progressivement disparu de la
première partie du 20ème siècle et n'a
plus du tout court aujourd'hui ces
bureaux centralisateurs sont fixés dans
la commune la plus peuplée du nouveau
canton sauf lorsque le nouveau canton
correspond exactement à l'ancien dans ce
cas c'est l'actuel chef lieu qui devient
bureau centralisateur dans les projets
de décret le nom du canton est définie
par cette commune du recentralisateur ou
par le nom d'un élément géographique
majeure à l'image de nombreux
intercommunalités des conseils généraux
au cours de leurs délibérations peuvent
proposer dans une motion complémentaire
au vote sur le projet de décret des noms
pour les cantons si ces propositions
correspondent bien à la réalité
géographique du canton le gouvernement
pourra reprendre ces dénominations dans
le projet de décret transmis au conseil
d'état il l'a déjà fait à plusieurs
reprises votre souci de veiller à ce
qu'un sentiment d'appartenance secret
autour de nouveaux cantons est donc
totalement partagée par le gouvernement
la réforme aura comme vous le soulignez
un impact sur la répartition de la
première fraction dit bourg centre de la
tôle de la dotation de solidarité rurale
pour les communes perdent en leur
qualité de chef lieu de canton et pour
celles qui ne rempliraient pas le
critère de la part de la population
communale dans la population cantonale
pour autant cette question ne se posera
réellement qu'en 2017 en effet la loi du
17 mai a prévu ce problème et la qualité
de chef lieu de canton est maintenue aux
communes qui la perdre jusqu'au prochain
renouvellement général des conseils
départementaux soit en 2015 les
giboulées gilles léger l'éligibilité aux
trois fractions de la dsr est appréciée
sur la base des données connues ou pro
mi janvier de l'année précédant celle de
la répartition la nouvelle carte
cantonale n'aura donc un impact sur
cette dotation qu'à compter de l'année
2010 cette année au cours de laquelle
sera prise en compte la situation des
communes au 1er janvier 2016 dans cet
intervalle le redécoupage de la carte
cantonale n'aura donc pas de conséquence
sur l'éligibilité des communes la dsr
bourse entre le gouvernement est
conscient de l'importance que revêt
cette dotation pour les communes
bénéficiaires en les aidant à remplir
une fonction essentielle de saturation
de leur territoire c'est pourquoi une
réflexion approfondie est actuellement
menée sur le sujet des nains des
annonces pourront sans doute être faite
très prochainement merci ce ministre
chers collègues souhaitez-vous réagir
aux propositions ministre
il madame la présidente d'abord
remercier monsieur le ministre des
prévisions des précisions qu'il a bien
voulu ma porte et notamment donc la
prise en compte du relief puisque nous
cantons ont déjà été saisie de ce
problème la deuxième c'est sûr
effectivement le chef lieu de canton la
nécessité effectivement de tenir compte
des avis locaux pour la dénomination 7,7
liés à l'histoire mais je crois que
c'est extrêmement important avec le
gouvernement est prêt si j'ai bien
compris à reprendre cette dénomination
certains certaines dénominations et la
troisième donc sur le problème financier
je mange ou aussi que le gouvernement
laisse du temps le temps de la réflexion
jusqu'en
2017 ça ne lève pas toutes les
incertitudes et je resterai vigilant sur
ce sujet qui a je crois me souvenir que
le ministre de l'intérieur avait déclaré
devant notre
assemblée que lorsqu'ils concernent la
gendarmerie elle serait recalibré en
fonction du profil des nouveaux cantons
et ce qui est vrai pour la gendarmerie
peut l'être aussi pour les autres
services publics et si on peut
comprendre la mutualisation je crois que
c'est une nécessité la proximité est un
atout qu'il faut bien sûr conservés donc
là dessus je serais extrêmement vigilant
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président karl l'ordre